สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องอาตี้สวั
สวัสดีครับนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนเย
ครับผมอ่ากลับมาเจอกันกลับมาเจอครูอตี้
ครูพี่เอ๋ในช่อง comprehensible ไยนะครับ
โอเคว้าววันนี้เรามาเจอกันแน่นอนถ้าเห็น
เรา 2 คนมาเจอกันก็ต้องเป็นเป็นวันอะไร
ครับวันจันทร์ค่ะอ่าใช่ครับดูเสื้อครู
อาตี้นี่วันศุกร์เสื้อครูเออ๋นี่วันอะไร
เนี่ยวันพฤหัสบหรือวัน
อาทิตย์โอเคเรามาเจอกันก็ต้องเป็นวัน
จันทร์สิใช่มั้ยอ่าวันจันใชเราชอบเจอกัน
วันจันทร์นะคะใช่ครับจริงๆแล้วน่าจะเจอ
กันวันศุกร์บ้างนะลองมั้ยลองมั้ยเดี๋ยว
อาทิตย์หน้าอาทิตย์หน้าอาจจะเจอกันวัน
ศุกร์อืนะครับอืได้ๆอ่ะวันวันจันทร์นะคะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันนี้วันจันทร์ที่ 29
ครับอู้ 29 แล้วใช่เกือบจะสิ้นเดือนแล้ว
เกือบจะอีกกี่วันอ่าอีก 3 วันครับอ้อวัน
นี้ 29 ก็ตอนนี้เนี่ยมันตอนเย็นแล้วก็ไม่
นับนับพรุ่งนี้พรุ่งนี้ก็คือ 30 แล้วก็
มะรืนนี้มะรืนนี้ 31 อีก 2 วันอีก 2 วัน
ก็สิ้นเดือนอี 2 วันสิ้นเดือนใช่ครับโอ
สิ้นเดือนแล้วเดือนอะไรจะไปแล้วคะอ่า
เดือนเดือนสิงหาคมกำลังจะไปครับเดือน
สิงหาคมนี้เดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะอ่าเดือน
สิงหาคมนี้เดือนที่ 8 เดือนที่ 8 นะคะใช่
ใช่ครับอปีพ.ศอะไรคะพ.ศ
2565 ครับ
2565  65 ใช่ปีค.ศอะไรคค.ศ
2022 ครับ 2022 ใชแล้วแล้วตอนนี้เราเจอ
กันเวลากี่โมงคะอ่าตอนนี้เราเจอกันตอน 19
น
เอ่อ 7 นอ 7 อ๋อ
7  19 นเดี๋ยวนะ 19 น 7 นใช่ๆๆ 197 นใช่
แล้วูเอ๋ไปคิด 10 ได้ยังไงออคิดว่ากำลัง
จะนอนออคิดว่าตรงนี้ใช่มยใช่ 197 น 19 น
เดี๋ยวนะ 19
นวันไหนครูอาตี้กับครูเอ๋เจอกันตอนตอน
กลางกลางวันอุ๊ยลิ้นทันตอนกลางวันนี่จะ
แปลกๆหน่อยจะแปลกใช่มั้ยอ่าโอเค 197 น
ครับอื 197 นแล้วนะคะนักเรียนคะครูอาตี้
ค่ะวันวันนี้นะก็เราเจอกันก็ไปทำธุระเนาะ
อ๋อใช่ๆๆชั่วโมงนี้ก็จะเป็นทำธุระอีก
ชั่วโมงนึงก็จะเป็นธุรกิจอ่าเกี่ยวกับ
ธุรกิจบ้างนะครับแต่วันนี้เราธุระก่อน
ธุระก่อนธุระครับธุระธุระคือไปทำธุระแหละ
อ่ามีงานมีอะไรบ้างนะครับไปทำไปทำธุระ
ต่างๆนอกบ้านไม่ได้อยู่บ้านนะไปขงนอกอื
ใช่นะคะเวลาเวลาที่ที่สมมุติว่าใครเขาจะ
ถามเราว่าอ้าวไปไหนถ้าเราไม่อยากจะบอกบ
ว่าไปทำอะไรอก็พูดว่าไปทำธุระนะคะใช่ครับ
อือฮึทำธุระเ้าก็จะโอเคไม่ถามต่อนะคะอ๋อ
แต่ว่าธุระมีอะไรบ้างนะคะอ่าถามนะบางคนก็
ถามธุระอะไรหรอ
แหมอยากรู้ไงอยากรู้บอกหน่อยบอกหน่อยไป
ธุระอะไรอยากอ้าบางทีก็บอกก็ได้ก็ไม่ต้อง
โกรธเนาะอืบางคนไม่อยากรู้เป็นคนห่วงใยอ
จะได้รู้ว่าไปนานมจะได้ดูบ้านให้เราบางที
เป็นเพื่อนบ้านใช่ๆอ๋อวันนี้นะคะครูอาตี้
อ่าวันนี้ไปธุระอะไรชวนครูอาตี้มาคุย
เรื่องแต่งงานอ๋องานแต่งงานใช่มั้ยชวนครู
อาตี้มาคุยเรื่องแต่งงานคือครูอาตี้กับ
เอ๋ไม่ได้แต่งงานกันนะคะอ่าใช่ครับครู
อาตี้แต่งงานไปแล้วอ้อเอ่ออาทิตย์ที่แล้ว
ครูอตี้ก็ไปงานแต่งงานมาเหมือนกันอ๋อ
เพิ่งไปมาดีเลยครูอตี้งั้นเอ๋จะถามครู
อาตี้นะคะอ้าถามได้เลยถามได้ใช่มั้ยคะถาม
ได้ครับอ่าไปงานแต่งงานใครคะอ่าไปงานแต่ง
งานของน้องน้องที่ทำงานที่เดียวกันกับครู
อาตี้เแต่งงานอ๋อแล้วน้องนี่เป็นเจ้าบ่าว
หรือเจ้าสาวอ่าน้องเป็นเอ่อเจ้าบ่าวเพราะ
ว่าเป็นผู้ชายอ๋อแล้วถ้าเจ้าสาวล่ะคะฮะ
ครับเจ้าสาวนี่ผู้หญิงเนาะออสาวก็ต้อง
เป็นผู้หญิงครับผู้ชายต้องแต่งงานกับผู้
หญิงแต่งงานกันไม่ใช่เดี๋ยวนักนักเรียน
น่ะไม่รู้เอ๊ะเจ้าบ่าวอะไรเจ้าสาวคืออะไร
อืผู้ชายเป็นเจ้าบ่าวก็คือลูกน้องครู
อาตี้อืแล้วก็มีแฟนก็เป็นเจ้าสาวใช่อือ่อ
แล้วเขให้การ์ดูอาตี้ใช่มั้ยคะใช่ครับให้
การ์ดูอาตี้มาด้วยอ๋อแล้วการ์ดสีอะไร
การ์ดของเค้าเนี่ยสีเขียวอ๋อสีเขียว
เหมือนข้างหลังครูอาตี้ใช่ๆเหมือนข้าง
หลังโคตี้ก็สีเขียวเพราะว่าในงานเนี้ยเขา
บอกว่าใครที่จะไปงานขอให้ขอให้ใส่เสื้อสี
เขียวอุยแล้วถ้าไม่มีสีเขียวโอเคอ่ะถ้า
ไม่มีไม่เป็นไรคูตี้ใส่เสื้อสีขาวไป
โอเคอ๋อคือคือถ้าเป็นเพื่อนสนิทใช่มยคะ
เป็นเพื่อนกันก็ใส่สีเขียวแต่ถ้าไม่มีก็
สีขาวอ่าสีขาวก็ได้นะครับอือฮึแต่เจ้า
บ่าวเจ้าสาวก็คือจะสีเขียวใช่เจ้าสาวสี
ขาวอ่าจะเป็นโทนสีเขียวอ่าสีเขียวอ่อนๆ
ใช่ครับอืดอกไม้ใบไม้อะไรก็สีเขียวนะคะ
ใช่ๆครับอือฮึครูอาตี้เวลาได้แล้วเแต่ง
ที่ไหนคะอ่าเแต่งแ่งที่จังหวัดกาญจนบุรี
ครับโออ๋อเข้าใจแล้วทำไมสีเขียวอ๋อ
กาญจนบุรีมีมีป่าไม้มีภูเขาเยอะใช่มั้ยมี
ต้นไม้เยอะอย่าบอกว่าโฮมพุเตยนะอ๋อไม่ถึง
ครับอยู่ใกล้ๆขับรถไปประมาณประมาณ 100 ก
อ๋อนอ่าไม่ไกลเป็นเป็นแต่งงานที่ไหนคะที่
บ้านที่โรงเรียนที่วัดหรือที่โรงแรมแรม
ที่รีอออ่าปกติคนไทยจะแต่งงานหลายๆที่ที่
ไหนที่สะดวกที่จะจัดงานก็จะแต่งได้ใช่
มั้ยครับแต่เอ่อน้องของครัวตี้แต่งที่
บ้านครับอือ่าแต่งที่บ้าน
ออครับแสดงว่าบ้านเ้าเป็นบ้านสวนมีมีที่
อ่าใช่ครับมีพื้นที่อ้อปกติปกติคนไทยคน
ไทยเวลาแต่งงานเราจะไปแต่งกันที่บ้านเจ้า
สาวอ๋อบ้านผู้หญิงอ่าบ้านของผู้หญิงที่
เป็นเจ้าสาวอ่าใช่บ้านอืเจ้าสาวเนี่ยเขา
เป็นเอ่อคนที่อยู่ที่
กาญจนบุรีก็เลยต้องไปไปแต่งงานที่
กาญจนบุรีอ้าวแล้วเจ้าบ่าวเป็นคนที่ไหนคะ
อ๋อเจ้าบ่าวเป็นคนจังหวัดเพชรบูรณ์โออ่า
สีเขียวเหมืออยู่ทางเหนืออยู่ทางเหนือ
ส่วนกาญจนบุรีอยู่ทางทิศตะวันตกค่ะอ่าใช่
ครับอ๋อเพชรบูรณ์ก็มีภูเขาเยอะๆใช่มีภ
กาญจนบุรีก็ภูเขาเยอะๆเข้าใจทำไมสีเขียว
อแล้วเอ่อเ่อครูอาตีเอ๊ยเแต่งกลางวันหรือ
แต่งเช้าหรือแต่งตอนเย็นหรือแต่งทั้งวัน
อืเ้าแต่งแต่งตอนเช้าครับออตอนเช้าอแล้ว
มีงานเช้ามีงานงานเที่ยงด้วยมั้ยคะอ่ามี
งานเช้าแล้วก็มีงานเที่ยงด้วยงานเช้าก็จะ
มีพระพระมาให้พรให้พรว่าอ้าให้พรเพื่อ
เพื่อให้เจ้าบ่าวเจ้าสาวนะครับได้ทำบุญ
ร่วมกันเอ๊ะเดี๋ยวๆครูเอ๋ให้ดูรูปมั้ยอ่า
ได้ครับมีรูปด้วยใช่มั้ยว้าวมามีรูปพระ
ให้พรแต่ไม่ใช่รูปของครูอาตี้นะคะใช่ๆๆ
ครูอาติไม่ได้มีรูปมาให้แต่ครูเอครูเอต
เตรียมรูปไว้เดี๋ยวครูเอหาก่อนอ้อดีครับ
ไหนครับอึบ
อ่ะโอเคอ๋อนี่ไงนี่ไงงานตอนเช้าใช่มั้ย
ใช่อืมงานงาน
เช้างเชอ๋องานเช้าก็คือมีทำบุญครับใช่มี
ทำบุญมีทำบุญคนไหนคนไหนเจ้าบ่าวคนไหนเจ้า
สาว
ครับ
เอ่อคนเจ้าบ่าวคนนี้เจ้าสาวใช่มั้ยคะอ้า
ไม่ใช่ไม่ใชู่ครูเอเดี๋ยวนักเรียนงงคนไหน
เจ้าบ่าวเจ้าบ่าวก็คือเจ้าบ่าวเนี่ยแปล
ว่าผู้ชายอ๋อคนนี้ค่ะเจ้าบ่าวอ่าเจ้าบ่าว
อ่ะสีแดงสีแดงเนี่ยเจ้าสาวอ่าเจ้าสาวก็
คือผู้หญิงคนที่เป็นคนที่แต่งงานเนี่ย
เป็นผู้หญิงเนี่ยเรียกว่าเจ้า
สาวค่ะ 2 คนนี้ใส่ชุดไทยนะคะครับอ่าเอ๊ะ
แล้วงานแต่งรุ่นน้องครูอาตี้นี่ใส่ชุดไทย
มั้ยคะงานชอ่าใส่ชุดไทยด้วยครับตอนเช้า
ใส่ชุดไทยอออ๋อก็ก็ก็คล้ายๆครูเอ๋เเนาะ
ใส่ชุดไทยแต่ชุดไทยมีหลายๆอย่างนะคะนัก
เรียนอืชุดไทยมีหลายแบบเลยค่ะก็ก็จะในรูป
นี้ก็จะมีพระนะคะครูอาตี้งานแต่งงานใช้
พักใช้พระเอไม่ใช่เชิญพระอ่านิมนต์พระ
เชิญพระกี่กี่รูปใช่มั้ยนิมนต์พระนิมนต์
พระเชญโอเคอ่าแปลว่าเชิญพระนั่นแหละ
เหมือนกันแต่ว่าใช้ภาษาพระนะอ่าใช่ครับน
นิมนต์พระระพระสงฆ์นะคะครับกี่รูปคะอ่า
นิมนต์พระเอ่อ 5 รูปครับออ 5 รูปเหรอคะ
ใช่ครับเ่อ 5 รูปได้เอ่อ 9 รูปได้ 3  3
รูปก็ได้ออก็ 3 ใช่ครับ 3 ถึง 9 นะใช่
ครับที่เป็นเอ่อเอ่อคนไทยเรียกเลขขี่อ๋อ
อ่า 4 เไม่ได้นะคะอ่า 4 ไม่ได้อือ่าฮะ 3
5  7 ได้มั้ยคะ 7 ได้ครับ 9 นะคะหรือมาก
กว่านี้ได้มอเอ่อมากกว่านี้ก็ได้ครับแต่
ต้องเป็นเลขขี่ออเป็นเลขเวลาครูอาตี้แต่ง
งานเนี่ยนิมนต์พระกี่รูปคะอ่าตอนครัวตี้
แต่งงานครัวตี้นิมนต์พระ 9 รูป 9 รูปนะคะ
อืครูเอ๋แต่งงานก็นิมนต์พระ 9 รูปเหมือน
กันนะคะคนไทยชอบเลข 9 นะคะแต่ว่าถ้าพระมี
งานเยอะๆก็โอเค 3 ได้อ่าใช่ครับอบางที
เอ่อที่วัดอาจจะมีพระเหลือน้อยมีพระไป
หลายที่ก็จะเหลือแค่ 5 รูปมาได้ 5 รูปมี
ไม่ถึงอ่ามีน้อยกว่าที่ที่นิมนต์นะครับอ
นะคะก็ก็ก็อันนี้ในรูปที่นักเรียนเห็นก็
จะเป็นเจ้าบ่าวกับเจ้าสาวครับนะคะนั่งฟัง
นะคะอ่าพระนะคะเดี๋ยวพระจะสวดแต่ตอนนี้
นี่ก็คือเอ่ออะไรนะอ่ะเรียกว่าพนมมือไหว้
พระใช่มั้ยใช่ไหว้พระครับแล้วพระก็จะสวด
นะคะสวดมนต์นะคะเราก็ฟังเนาะครูอาตี้ตอน
ครูอาตี้แต่งงานน่ะนั่งพระนานมั้ยคะเอ่อ
นานนิดหน่อยครับนานนิดหน่อยอ๋อแล้วที่ไป
งานไม่มากกาญจนบุรีไม่อือฮึพระสวดมนต์นาน
มคะครับก็ไม่นานเหมือนกันครับไม่นานอือฮึ
ดีจังอืงานเนี้ยของครูเอ๋นาน
มากทำไมทำไมพระสวด
นานน่าจะอายุเยอะ
สดไม่ทราบเหมือนกันค่ะคือเมีบทสวดแบบแบบ
แบบแบบสั้นๆเนาะแล้วก็ดวแบบยาวๆของกูเ
เนี่ยาวมากนะคะอืกระบทสวดยาวะอ่าทีนี้
เนี่ยครูอติเป็นานแต่งงานตอนเช้าเนี่ยทำ
บุญแล้วครูอาตี้อยู่ในทีมยกขันหมากด้วยมย
อ่าอยู่ในทีมขันหมากด้วยมยอยู่ครับอ่ะ
อยู่ในทีมขันหมากด้วยขันหมากออครูเอ๋ลืม
อันนี้คือออ่าขนมขันหมากอ่าขันหมากคือ
อะไรครับครูเอ๋ขันหมากก็จะเป็นอุ้ยครูเอ๋
ลืมลืมเอาชุดขันหมากอะไรคือขันหมากนัก
เรียนงงเอ๊ะขันหมากคืออะไรมีขันแล้วก็มี
หมาก
อ่าใช่ๆๆมีมีมีขันแล้วก็มีหมากคือเอ่อขัน
หมากเนี่ยคือเขาจะมีพานเดี๋ยวครุเอ๋วาด
รูปแล้วกันเนาะอ่าฮอโอเคตัวเองไม่ได้ลืม
เอารูปขันหมากมานะคะสมัยก่อนใช่มยคนไทยคน
ไทยเราก็จะกินหมาก่ะแล้วก็เอาใส่ขันไป
เยอะๆเพราะขันเนี่ยใบใหญ่ใส่ของได้เยอะ
ค่ะครับอืมเดี๋ยวนะคะอ่าเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋ปึ๊บ
ลบนิดนึงนะคะเจะมีพานแบบ
[เพลง]
นี้นะ
คะแล้วในนี้ก็ก็จะมีลูกหมากลูกหมากก็จะ
เป็นสีเขียวๆ
อ่านะคะหมากเป็นผลไม้ชนิดนึงใช่เป็นผลไม่
ใช่ผลไม้มั้ผลไม้มเป็นผลไม้แล้วก็มีมีพลู
นะคะ
อ่าอันเนี้ยเป็นขันหมากสำหรับให้คนเคี้ยว
เป็นหมากจริงๆอือฮึเคี้ยวแล้วก็จะมีมีพาน
อีกพาน
นึงเป็น
พานอ่าเป็นพานอะไรล่ะอ๋อเป็นพา
เทียนใช่ม
เทียน
อุ๊บอ่ะอันนี้เป็น
เทียนเทียนนะคะนักเรียนแบบนี้อเทียนอาฮะ
อ่าเทียนนะคะก็จะมีภาพปิดเอาไว้เนาะอ่า
แล้วก็มี
พานอันนี้เป็นอุยวาดไม่สวยนะคอตี้อ่าอัน
นี้ใส่อะไรครับใส่เงินออว้าวใส่เงินด้วยอ
เงินอ่ะดอลลาร์ก็ได้นะ
คะมีขันหมากมีธูปเทียนแล้วก็มีเงินมีอะไร
อีกน่าจะประมาณ 3-4 พาน่ะเนาะแล้วก็ขนมนะ
คะอือ่าก็จะต้องมีตัวนี้นะคะอันนี้อาจจะ
เป็นแหวนมั้นแหวนแต่งงานเป็นสร้อยเป็น
ต่างหูอืคะอันที่ 3 เนี่ยอ่อแต่ว่าบาง
บ้านอ้าเค้าก็จะมีขนมแบบนี้
อ่าเป็นขนมไทยใช่มั้ยใช่ถ้าแต่งงานแบบไทย
ไทยแท้ๆก็จะเป็นขนมแบบนี้ใช่ครับอ่าเป็น
ขนมเ่อคนไทยเรียกขนมมงคลใช่มั้ยกินแล้วทำ
ให้มีความสุขอ่าเป็นขนมแบบหวานหวาน
เนาะขนมไทยส่วนใหญ่เป็นขนมหวานนะครับอคือ
คือขนมอย่างเงี้ยถ้าจะแต่งงานคือไปบอกเ้า
ได้เลยว่าอือไปที่ที่ร้านทำขนมไทยอ่ะค่ะ
นักเรียนแล้วก็บอกเขาว่าขอเอ่อขอขนมแต่ง
งานกี่ชุดก็บอกเไปใช่ง่ายมา 2 ชุดเนาะ 2
ชุดครับอ่า 2 ชุดแบบนี้อืตอนครูอาตี้แต่ง
งานมีขนมแบบนี้มั้ยคะมีมีอะไรบ้างในเนี้ย
ครูอาตี้เดี๋ยวครูเอ๋จะถามครูอาตี้อ๋อ
ต้องมีแน่นอนที่เป็นเอ่อทอันนี้ทองหยอด
ใช่มั้ยอ่าโอเคเอาอันนึงทองหยอดอ่าอนี้ก็
หวานทองหยอดสีทองสีเหลืองทำมาจากไข่อ่า
ต่อไปอันที่ 2 เป็นฝอยทองค่ะ 3 อันที่ 3
เป็นเม็ดขนุน 4 อันที่ 4 เป็นทองหยิบอ่า
เอ่อหลักๆเนี่ยต้องมี 4 อย่างนี่เนาะอ่า
ใช่ครับแต่ว่าเขาจะมีขนมทั้งหมดน่ะน่าจะ
ถ้าแบบไทยน่าจะมี 9 อย่างใช่มั้ยคะโอ้กัว
ที่ี้จำไม่ได้แล้วมีอะไรบ้างน่าจะมี 9
อย่างแต่หลักๆเนี่ย 4 อย่างก่อนนะคะทอง
ทองหยอดอือฮึอ่าฝอยทองเม็ดขนุนแล้วก็ทอง
หยิบแล้วก็อ่ะ 5
ค่ะข้าวเหนียวอ่ะข้าวเหนียวกวนนี่ใช่มั้ย
เค้าเรียกว่าข้าวเหนียวกวนหรือข้าวเหนียว
ข้าวเหนียวแก้วอ๋อข้าวเหนียวแก้วโอเคหาน
นะคะอแล้วก็อ่อ
6 อันนี้อันนี้อะไไรนครับอ่าอ๋อจ่ามงกุฎ
ใช่มยใช่โอ้ยครัวตี้รู้จัก
ด้วยแล้วก็
7 ขนมจันทรึป่าอ๋อขนมจันทรมันเหมือนลูก
จันทร์โอเค 8 อันนี้ครูเอ๋ไม่รู้จักอะไร
ครูเอกแต่งงานไม่มีตัวนี้อันนี้อันที่ 8
อ๋ออันนี้เหมือนหน้าตตาเหมือนขนมไหว้พระ
จันทร์เลยครับ
ใช่ชื่ออะไรสักอย่างครูเอจำไม่ได้นัก
เรียนเหรอครับแล้วก็อที่ 9 โอเค
อ่าอันที่ 9 นี่เป็นขนมชั้นใช่มั้ยขใช่
อ่าใช่ค่ะขนมชั้นอันที่ 8 ใช่ขนมปั้น 10
มั้ยไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ใช่มยอันนี้ทำจากถั่ว
แล้วก็ไข่
อ๋อถั่วกับไข่ถั่วกวนอเหมือนอย่างอ่ะขนม
ไยพระจันททองด้วยตรงเนี้ยมีทองด้วยอ๋อ
เอ่อนักเรียนคะครูเออ๋น่ะจำขนมไทยทั้งหมด
ไม่ได้เพราะเวลาครูเออ๋แต่งงานเนี่ยครู
เออ๋ไม่ได้ใช้ขนม
ไทยโอเคอ่าก็มีขนมอยู่ในขันหมากอยู่ใน
ขบวนขันหมากด้วยใช่มั้ยครับใช่ครูเอดใช่
ขนมแบบนี้ค่ะครูอาตี้อืมโอเคอันอันนี้
เป็นขนมแต่งงานของครูเออ๋เพราะว่าครูเออ๋
เป็นไทยจีนอ๋อใช่ตอนกัวตี้แต่งงานก็ใช้
ขนมพวกนี้เหมือนกันขนมถั่วกวนขนมข้าวพอง
ขนมเอ่อ
ถั่วข้าวพองตัวนี้ขนุมถั่วอันนี้งาอันนี้
ถ่ววนอันนี้อ่าฟักเขียวเชื่อมใช่อ่ะฟัก
เชื่อมโอเคหวานหวาน
น่ะแต่งงานเนี่ยจะมีแต่ขนมหวานหวานแล้ว
ต้องมีเป็นคู่ใช่มั้ยคะอ่าใช่ครับอ่า
เพราะว่าเอ่อเวลาแต่งงานเราแต่งงานเกิด
เป็นคู่มีผู้ชายมีผู้หญิงมีเจ้าบ่าวมี
เจ้าสาวเพราะฉะนั้นขบวนขันหมากก็จะมีเอ่อ
คนที่ถือถาดขนมเนี่ยเป็นคู่คู่ไปอืแล้วเา
ก็จะในในในขบวนตรงเนี้ยค่ะนักเรียนคะเาจะ
มีขนมอีก 2 ตัวอันเนี้ยขนมปลาปลานะคะอ๋อ
แล้วก็ก็ขนมเปี๊ยะขนมหมูอันนี้ก็คือว่าอ
รักกันแล้วก็ปลาเนี่ยเอันนี้เป็นไทยจีนก็
จะบอกว่าปลาว่ายน้ำได้ดี
อ๋อความหมายนะคะออ่ะที่ครูอาตี้ไปงานแต่ง
งานมาน่ะเาแบบแบบไทยหรือว่า
แบบไทยจีนอ่าเป็นแบบไทยครับแบบไทยก็เป็น
ขนมแบบนี้นะคะใช่ครับแล้วก็แต่งงานกันที่
บ้านเนาะอ่าใช่ที่บ้านที่บ้านพอเราเห็น
อ่ะแล้วที่ซองเอ้ยไม่ใช่เราเรียกที่ซอง
เนาะที่การ์ดเค้าเขียนมยคะบุฟเฟ่ต์โต๊ะ
จีนคอกเทลอ่าส่วนใหญ่เอ่องานแต่งงานเก็จะ
ใช้โต๊ะจีนเพราะว่าเพราะว่าง่ายอือ่าใน
งานแต่งงานที่คูตี้ไปก็มีเอ่อโต๊ะจีน
เหมือนกันโอทคูเอกขอขอไปที่รูปนะคะอโต๊ะ
จีนโต๊ะจีนก็คือแบบนี้เนาะอือฮึ
นี่
โเห็นมั้ยคะคุณอาตี้อ้าเห็นครับอโต๊ะโต๊ะ
จีนคือเป็นโต๊ะแล้วก็เป็นอาหารจีนใช่มั้ย
คะคุณอิใช่ครับใช่ครับแล้วก็ให้คนที่ไป
งานเนี่ยมานั่งรวมๆกันอยู่ที่โต๊ะอ่าใช่
ครับเอ๊ะถ้าเราแบบเอาโต๊ะจีนแต่ว่าไม่เอา
อาหารจีนได้มั้ยคะ
อ่า๊ะโต๊ะจีนเหมายถึงอาหารจีนอยู่บนโต๊ะ
ถ้าเราเอาโต๊ะอย่างเดียวไม่เอาอาหารไม่ๆๆ
เ้าเรียกโต๊ะเหมือนโต๊ะจีนเหมือนกันแต่
ข้างในเป็นอาหารไทยเป็นต้มยำอ๋อเป็นยำ
วุ้นเส้นอือือเพราะอย่างโต๊ะที่ครูเอ๋เอา
มาให้ครูอาตี้ดูเนี่ยเป็นอาหารจีนเลยนะคะ
อันนี้เป็นที่โรงแรมนะแล้วก็ทั้งทั้งหมดอ
นี้เป็นอาหารไทยจีนหรืออาหารจีนแต่บางคน
บอกอยากได้โต๊ะจีนในงานแต่งงานแต่อาหารขอ
เป็นอาหารไทยก็ได้เนาะอ๋อได้ครับได้ครับ
สั่งได้ครับอาจจะมีเอ่อเอ่อแกงเขียวหวาน
อ่าแกงส้มต้มข่าไก่ได้ครับสั่งได้ได้นะคะ
แต่ว่าเสิร์ฟแบบโต๊ะจีนโต๊ะจีนอือฮึนะคะ
วิธีการเสิร์ฟแ่าค่ะเเรียกว่าเสิร์ฟแบบ
โต๊ะจีนคือนั่งอยู่เฉยๆแล้วก็อาหารมา
เสิร์ฟใช่ก็จะมีอาหารทั้งหมด 9 อย่างอื
ครับบางที่ก็ 8  8-9 นะคะอก็เป็นโต๊ะจีน
อ่าถ้าเป็นแบบนี้นี่เอ๊ะแบบบุฟเฟ่ต์เหรอ
อ่าแบบนี้เป็นบุฟเฟ่ต์ครับอ่าทุกคนที่ไป
งานสามารถตักเองได้เลยอ่าอยากกินอะไรก็
เลือกตักอ่าที่ตัวเองชอบที่ตัวเองอยากกิน
ได้เลยแล้วแบบนี้ล่ะคะเป็นอะไรคะอ่าอ้อ
แบบนี้เป็นงานเอ่อคอกเทลครับอ๋อเป็นอ่า
ถ้าแบบนี้ก็จะเมื่อยหน่อยครับคูตี้ไปงาน
คอกเทลคูตี้เมื่อยครับเพราะว่าไม่ได้
นั่งไม่มีเก้าอี้นั่งเป็นงานที่ไม่มี
เก้าอี้แล้วแถมแพงด้วย
นะเข้าใจเว่าแพงเว้ย่าอาหารในงานคอกเทล
นี่แพงมากอ่ามีเยอะมากแล้วก็ชิ้นเล็กๆ
ครับอ่าเวลากินต้องกินหลายๆชิ้นครูออจี้
ชอบแบบไหนคะชอบโตจีนบุฟเฟ่ตหรือคอกเทลอ่า
เอ่อคูตี้คิดว่าดีดีคนละแบบถ้าเป็นคอกเทล
คูตี้ก็กินแล้วก็เดินไปคุยกับคนนี้เดินไป
คุยกับคนนั้นเดินไปคุยกับคุณเดินไปรอบๆ
เจอคนเยอะแยะได้พูดได้คุยสนุกแต่แต่ไม่
ได้นั่งนะนั่งเหนื่อเหนื่อยใช่อ้าถ้าเป็น
ถ้าเป็นบุฟเฟต์่ะคะอ่าถ้าเป็นบุฟเฟ่ต์เรา
ก็ตักอาหารที่เราต้องการที่เราชอบมาแล้ว
ก็นั่งมีโต๊ะนั่งแล้วก็คุยกับเพื่อนได้
แต่ก็เพื่อนก็จะได้คุยแค่เพื่อนที่อยู่ใน
โต๊ะที่นั่งโต๊ะเดียวกับเราอหรือไม่ก็ไป
เจอกันตอนตักอาหารอ่าใช่ๆนิดหน่อยนิด
หน่อยแล้วโต้จีนล่ะค่ะอ่าโต๊ะจีนก็เหมือน
กันอ่าคล้ายๆกับบุฟเฟ่ต์แต่เราเราไม่ต้อง
เดินไปตักอาหารเองไม่ต้องเรานั่งรอเดี๋ยว
อาหารจะมาอืแต่ต้องเลือกคนนั่งที่รู้จัก
กันนะถ้าไม่รู้จักใช่ๆถ้าไม่รู้จักกันก็
อืมคุยได้นิดหน่อยอ่าคุยได้นิดหน่อยไม่
สนุกอ่าถ้าไปกับคนรู้จักกันไปกับเพื่อน
นั่งโต๊ะเดียวกับเพื่อนก็คุยสนุกเลยใช่
แล้วก็ถ้าไม่รู้จักกันก็อายไม่กล้ากินอีก
ใช่เอ๊ะครูอาตี้ทีนี้เนี่ยเวลาเวลาที่เรา
ได้การ์ดมาเรายังมีเวลาใช่มั้ยคะอ่ามี
เวลาครับเราได้การ์ดมาแล้วเรารู้ะอ่ะแต่ง
งานต่างจังหวัดแต่งงานที่บ้านนะคะแล้วก็
อาหารเป็นโต๊ะจีนเป็นบุฟเฟตหรือเป็น
คอกเทลนะคะตัวนี้เป็นส่วนหนึ่งที่จะทำให้
เรารู้ว่าเราต้องใส่เสื้อผ้าแบบไหนอ่าใช่
ครับผู้ชายสบายๆอ่าสบายๆใส่เสื้อแขนสั้น
หรือแขนยาวก็ได้กางเกงขายาวอ่าใช่ครับเ
แต่ผู้หญิงเจะจะจะเยอะหน่อยนะคะคือผู้
หญิงเยอะทุกงานครับนักเรียนนักเรียนต้อง
รู้ว่าผู้หญิงเยอะทุกงานคือผู้หญิงต้อง
รู้ว่าแต่งงานตอนกลางวันหรือแต่งงานแต่ง
งานที่ไหนแต่งงานชุดก็จะไม่เหมือนกันนะ
อืมใช่ครับจะไม่เหมือนกันแล้วก็ต้องดูว่า
เจ้าสาวใส่ชุดอะไรนะคะแต่เราจะไม่ใส่สี
ขาวไปนะคะ้าอ๋อออฮะต้องใส่สีสีขาวเป็นของ
เจ้าสาวแต่ถ้าเจ้าสาวใส่ชุดไทยสีครีมออื
หรือสีชมพูเราก็ไม่ใส่สีชมพูเราก็ต้องรู้
นะคะอืออ๋อครูอาตี้แล้วอย่างเนี้ยคนไทย
เราเนี่ยรู้แล้วว่าเคมีงานเลี้ยงแบบนี้
ครับ
มีทำบุญแบบนี้เราจะไปช่วงไหนช่วงทำบุญ
ครับทำบุญปึ๊บตอนเช้าอือฮึอ่าเอ้ยตอนเช้า
ก่อนทำบุญเมีแหกเ่อขันหมากก่อนโอเคอันนี้
อันนี้อ่ายกขันหมากเนี่ยค่ะมีขันหมาก
อันเนี้ยใช่มั้ยคะครับอ่ะแหกขันหมากมา
ช่วงนี้อ่าไปช่วงอ่าอะไรนะเมื่อกี้ครูเอ๋
ให้ดูช่วง
ฟัง
พระหรือว่าไปช่วงเดี๋ยวนะครุเอ๋มีรูปอีก
ช่วง
อ่าตักบาตรอ่าอันนี้ก็เป็นช่วงทำบุญเสร็จ
ก็มาตักบาตรด้วยกันน่ะใช่ครับหรือบหรือ
เป็นช่วงที่คุเอกอ่ะลืมเอรูปอ่านี่ๆๆๆ
ช่วงนี้ช่วงรถน้ำสั่งใช่มยอ๋อออมีช่วง
ช่วงไอ้นี่ก่อนค่ะอัดน้ำมนต์อ่าช่วงที่
ที่พระให้น้ำมนต์ใช่มั้ยหลังจากที่ทำบุญ
เสร็จแล้วพระก็จะเอ่อลดน้ำมนต์ด้วยอืแล้ว
ก็มีช่วงชุดนี้เป็นชุดอ่าช่วงรถน้ำสังข
ใช่รถน้ำสังขอันนี้เป็นรถน้ำสังขอุยนี่
ครูเอ๋ใช่มยเนี่ยยังสาวอยู่เลยว้าวๆๆๆ 10
ปีที่แล้วผอาตี้ 10 ปีที่
แล้วอ๋อทุกอย่างสีแดงหมดนะคะนักเรียนฮะ
อ่าฮะไม่ไม่ใช่ครูเอกชอบสีแดงนะคะอึอัน
นี้เป็นของยืมจากวัดค่ะวัดวัดมีสีแดงออ๋อ
นึกว่าเป็นงานของคนจีนก็จะมีสีแดงเยอะ
หน่อยนะครับเอ่องานครูเอ๋เป็นแบบไทยผสม
จีนอ๋อนะคะไทยจีนอาฮะก็ช่วงรดน้ำสังขซึ่ง
ที่รดน้้ำสังขก็คือจะมีมีอะไรบ้างคะครู
อาตี้อ่ามีเอ่อพวงมาลัยใช่มั้ยครับพวง
มาลัยที่เอามาใชค่ะเอ่อคล้องคอคล้องคอ
เจ้าบ่าวแล้วก็เจ้าสาวใช่มั้ยครับอืใช่
ค่ะอันที่ 2 อะไรคะอันที่ 2 เป็นสายมงคล
สายมงคลที่ใส่ที่บนหัวของเจ้าสาวและเจ้า
บ่าวอ่าเพื่อจะได้รู้ว่า 2 คนเนี้ยคู่กัน
ค่ะอันที่ 3 ค่ะมี 2 อันที่ 3 อ้าอันที่ 3
เป็นเ่อหอยสังขครับเป็นหอยชนิดหนึงชื่อ
หอยสังขค่ะอันที่ 4 ค่ะอ่าอันที่ 4 ก็
เป็นน้ำอ่าก็คือน้ำมนตนะครับเป็นน้ำเอ่อ
ศักดิ์สิทธิ์ที่พระพระให้พรลงไปในน้ำแล้ว
นะครับค่ะอืก็จะเอาน้ำเนี่ยใส่ในหอยสั
เนาะใช่อ่าก็ก็เอ๊ะอันอันที่ 5 ค่ะอันนี้
ไครูเอไม่รู้อะไรเพราะงานครูเอ๋ไม่มีอ๋อ
อันนี้อคูตี้คิดว่าน่าจะเป็นน้ำอบอ๋อหอมๆ
เวลารดลงไปแล้วก็จะมีกลิ่นหอมๆอ่าน้ำสั่ง
ก็จะมีกลิ่นหอมๆของน้ำบอืค่ะแล้วก็อันที่
5 ค่ะอ่าอันที่ 5 เป็นแป้งเจิมอ่าเวลา
นักเรียนไปงานแต่งงานของคนไทยอ่ะก็จะมี
จุดแป้งเจิมอยู่บนหน้าผักอ่านะคะเค้าก็จะ
เจิมใชให้ดูเลยะกันนะคะดูอ่ามีมั้ยเจิม
หรือเปล่าเจิมหรือยังอ่ะนี่ใส่สายมงคลใช่
มั้ยใช่ๆสายศีลมงคลโอเคอ่ะนี่ไงนี่ไงที่
หน้าผากครูเอ๋มีแป้งเจิมสีขาวๆนักเรียน
เห็นมั้ยอ่าเห็นมั้ยคะเห็นมั้ยแล้วก็ใส่
พวงมาลัยด้วยน่าเมื่อกี้นี้อันนี้พวง
มาลัยเอ่อเค้าเรียกอะไรนะได้มงคลใช่มั้ย
อ่าลใสแล้วอื
ครับอ่ะอันนี้ที่คุอาตี้ไปงานแต่งของรุ่น
น้องมาก็แบบนี้ใช่มยคะใช่ครับใส่แบบนี้
เหมือนกันใส่พวงมาลัยใส่สายมงคลแล้วก็รด
น้ำสังเหมือนกันทีนี้เนี่ยสำหรับคนไทยเรา
จะเข้าใจแต่สำหรับนักเรียนเนี่ยนักเรียน
จะสงสัยว่าเอ๊ะเวลารดน้ำสังคือนี่เห็น
มั้ยคะอ่าได้มงคลเสร็จก็จะมีผู้ใหญ่เขาก็
จะเอาน้ำใส่น้ำเนี่ยใส่ในหอยสังขอืใช่
ครับหอยสังอันนี้แล้วก็เอาไปรรถที่มือ
ต้องพูดอะไรอ๋อก็เอ่อพูดคำอวยพรนะครับให้
เจ้าบ่าวแล้วก็เจ้าสาวรักกันรักกันนานๆนะ
ครับแล้วก็เอ่อ
เอ่อช่วยกันช่วยกันทำงานช่วยกันดูแลทั้ง
คู่ดูแลกันและกันอ่าจะได้รักกันนานๆผู้
หญิงก็ดูแลผู้ชายผู้
ใชใช่เจ้าบ่าวก็ดูแลเจ้าสาวเจ้าสาวก็ดูแล
เจ้าบ่าวใช่ครับนะคะบางทีก็บอกให้มีลูก
อ่ามีลูกเร็วๆใช่มั้ยอ่ามีลูกเร็วๆมีลูก
เยอะๆนะคะอือนะคะก็ถ้านักเรียนไม่รู้จะ
พูดอะไรนักเรียนพูดภาษาอังกฤษได้มั้ยอ่า
ใช่ครับพูดภาษาอังกฤษได้นะครับอ่าแต่ถ้า
จะพูดภาษาไทยก็พูดว่าขอให้รักกันนานๆอ่า
ใช่ครับขอให้มีความสุขมากๆนะคะอือขอให้มี
ลูกเร็วๆมีลูกเต็มบ้านมีหลานเต็มเมืองอ
แปลว่ามีลูกเยอะๆ
ใช่ให้มีลูกเยอะๆโอเคทีนี้ครูอาตี้คะครับ
อ่ะรู้แล้วว่าต้องพูดอะไรนะคะรู้แล้วว่า
อาหารเป็นอะไรแล้วต้องซื้อของขวัญหรือว่า
ต้องใส่อ๋อใช่ครับต้องใส่ซองอือ่าใส่เงิน
ลงไปในซองซองที่เขาให้เรามาครับเราก็จะ
ได้ซองเอาการ์ดเนี่ยออกเอาเงินใส่ลงไปแทน
อ่าใช่ครับคำถามที่นักเรียนจะถามครูเอก
บ่อยๆใส่เท่าไหร่อ๋อใส่เท่าไหร่ใช่มั้ย
ครับก็ถ้าเป็นคูตี้นะคูตี้ก็จะใส่เงิน
เนี่ยจำนวนเป็นเลขคู่ค่ะอ่าอย่างเช่น
อย่าง 20 บาทอ่าเอ่อ 800 ค่ะอ่ะ 400 อ่า
1,000 อ่า 2,000 ใส่เป็นเลขคู่ค่ะคือจะ
มากจะน้อยก็อยู่ที่เค้าเคยมางานแต่งเรา
อ่าใช่แล้วเค้าใส่เท่าไหร่สมมุติว่าเค้า
ใส่งานแต่งเรา
800 เราก็ต้องใส่งานแต่งเค้า 1,000 ใช่
นะคะหรือว่าทั้งบอกไม่เคยมางานแต่งชันชัน
ไม่เคยไปนักเรียนก็ดูที่ว่าแต่งงานที่ไหน
ราคาอาหารประมาณเท่าไหร่นะคะสนิทกันแค่
ไหนแล้วก็ค่อยใส่ซองไปอันเนี้ยใส่เงินไป
ในซองอันนี้ง่ายไม่ต้องคิดซื้ออะไรให้คน
ไทยไม่ค่อยซื้อเนาะอออือไม่รู้จะซื้ออะไร
ให้ก็ใส่เงินแล้วก็ใส่ซองให้ในงานแต่งงาน
นะคะได้เหมือนกัน
นะครับแต่ถ้าลืมอ่ะไม่ได้เอาซองไปอ่าไม่
ได้เอาซองไปก็ไปขอซองที่ที่งานมีซองมยขอ
ซองอีกซองนึงมีลืมเอามาอยู่บ้านค่ะเมีให้
นะคะครับโอเคค่ะคลิปนี้หมดเวลาแล้วเนาะ
ใช่หมดเวลาแล้วเดี๋ยวเรากลับมาเจอกันใหม่
คลิปหน้านะครับเราจะไปไหนไปทำอะไรกัน
เดี๋ยวรอติดตามเราได้ใหม่ในช่อง
comprehensible  Thai วันนี้เรา 2 คน
ต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วครับพี่เอ๋อ่าสวัสดีครับ
พี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูอาตี้สวัสดีครับนัก
เรียนบ๊าย
บาย